he's been talking about Islam for a
while now even before he converted I've
heard him that's he's the reason I even
knew what the Quran is because he was
talking about it I was like oh that must
be like the Islamic Bible like I have
been so unaware about everything of the
Islamic faith like I didn't even know if
Islam and Muslim were the same thing
like I had no idea like this [ __ ] was so
foreign to me it just never came up we
lived in an Italian neighborhood we
moved from the Italian neighborhood to
the Irish neighborhood they were both
right next door so that's all we did was
the Italian Neighborhood Italian and
Irish people were my life and to think
like a quarter of the globe is Muslims
is mind-boggling like that's that's
absolutely insane so this is Tate
praising Islam and just basically
talking about it before he converted
Islam fixes a lot of the problems that
men are currently facing the problems
we're discussing on this show Islam
fixes all of them right that's the first
thing for a second what's going on on
his chest does he have a giant cat or
something that's a cobra and a lion and
I'm not a Muslim right if I had to
choose a religion I would because I live
in Orthodox Christian country I go to
the Orthodox Christian Church I donate
twenty thousand dollars a month to the
church the church the church in Romania
is very powerful and I like having
church friends so I give them a lot of
money right so I would guess I'm an
Orthodox Christian but if I had to bet
on one religion as if I were betting on
the stock market for the future
you have to bound this mom
because Muslims are intolerant and I'm
not and I'm not saying that
disrespectfully because if you're
tolerant of everything then you stand
for nothing yeah Christians are so
tolerant now you don't believe it they
have gay pastors that I'm not even
anti-gay but if the book says don't have
like what yeah what do you believe in
now right yeah you're tall if you're
tolerant of everything you stand for
nothing
I can walk through
London with a t-shirt saying Jesus is
gay and nothing will happen to me if I
did the same thing with the Islamic
Prophet I'd be dead before I got to the
end of the street boom see but that's
not okay I'm sorry like you can say like
what how is that okay like calm down if
the religion is about love then it it
like the thing with Christianity is and
the thing with Jesus when he picked his
disciples and he went out looking for
them he did not pick the holiest among
the holy he picked out this ragtag a
bunch of screwed up people and changed
them and brought them to to light so he
didn't walk around going yeah you're not
good enough for me you're not good
enough for me and that is all that is
why we tolerate a lot of things because
that is what he taught us to do we to
tolerate everything no he taught us to
love unconditionally to pray for the
people that hurt us to pray for the
people that are uh astray so do you to
bring them in he wanted P he wanted us
to be Fishers of Men to go out fishing
and bringing in bringing in a news let's
just say you blatant disrespect though
like if someone was walking or if you
were really like super Christian and
someone was walking around with like
Jesus was gay and pro-choice like you
wouldn't be like I mean I guess that's
what they teach but I don't know I'm
trying to think about it no no you're
right like yeah as a human would it be
maybe right you're taught to just
pray for that person so pray for that
person and be an example of Jesus is
Love doesn't hope that they they come to
they come doesn't Islam teach peace and
everything too so that's what I'm also
confused about like saying would it be
the radicals that go and kill someone
for insulting the Islamic Prophet or
like what's the difference between the
Die Hard Christians seeing something
like that and then the Die Hard Muslims
seeing someone walk like because I want
to know how how big this how big this
that part of the belief is to the you
know what the thing is I don't think
there are based on what we're learning
so far necessarily degrees of Muslims
of Christians and and when you say die
hard Muslim I mean we we can't talk
about radicals who twist the religion
and our terrorists like they're a
separate group who say they're Muslim
but they're really just terrorist
lunatics right do they even like are
they even Muslims really because I don't
think you are a Muslim if you're doing
like you're just not a Muslim so like
what actually are they well they think
they are are the way Christian but like
who know like this is all [ __ ] that
we've been told like like I would like
to ask like an actual Muslim like get
the I think I'm organizing a podcast
with something yeah but I think like
asking them about like that kind of
stuff and like what do they believe in
that inclines them to go and do [ __ ]
like that but what is this comment that
Tate just made you know by if I got to
the end of the street I'd be dead by the
atomic outside the end of the street I
guess it's just because they don't and I
know he's speaking in hyperbole but but
if it's all about love love includes
tolerance it does it includes compassion
and it and the way to God According To
Jesus is through him and learning that
love and that compassion and he he
changed people with that he he
accomplished it and he proved that it
can be done so I'm not on board although
truly Tate Tate has spoken with more um
severity than anyone else we've seen
yeah I know he speaks in hyperbole but
if you guys would answer in the comments
too move your freaking glass I'm
starting to understand the Islamic faith
a lot more than I knew a few weeks ago
I'm not close to anywhere of knowing it
fully at all but I'm starting again just
scratching the surface but there's a lot
on the side I've seen nothing but peace
and everything so then where does the
line come where you're not tolerant but
then you go and it turns to violence
like I said is it the radicals that do
that that see that and they're not
tolerant but maybe you're supposed to be
loving as a Muslim do you see what I'm
saying yeah so I see what you're saying
it's it's confusing it's confusing but
then again is he speaking in hyperbole
who knows so let's just keep watching
and I respect people who stick up for
what they believe in yeah excited about
me believing in it I respect them
because they they believe and they will
defend Muslims are the only people who
will defend their religion they will
defend their beliefs they refuse to be
mocked they refuse to be insulted and I
respect that about them I respect that
that's an amazing thing about them right
and the third point is and I've been all
around the world some of the best
countries in the world today are the
first world Muslim nations yeah Qatar
you can go to Qatar you can fall asleep
with a million dollars on your lap in
the middle of the street nothing's gonna
happen
in Qatar actual I gotta find the the
documentaries and the footage I've seen
of the way that they treat human beings
in order to build the amazing stadiums
and skyscrapers and all the things that
they have that look so [ __ ] beautiful
because that's where Tate is yeah don't
try to sell me on Qatar it's so safe
it's so certified women everyone's
married every woman obeys her husband
every single woman has four or five six
kids big families all the things we're
talking about all the problems we have
here right they've got none of that none
of it because of Islam Islam keeps
Society in the role that doesn't sound
good to me what that every woman has to
obey their man she's a human being with
thoughts of her own and opinions of her
own and desires of her own you know I
believe in a you know I I support the
traditional structure but listen to him
that sounds a lot better than what goes
on here you know
either of them sound good I don't want
to choose that where I have to obey and
have six kids even if I don't want to
and I or the the girls who were running
around on Instagram and acting like
[ __ ] and having abortions neither of
those things sounds good to me it's it's
that they're both extreme family sounds
bad to you like I just don't who says
they're happy who says these women are
happy they're obedient that's not happy
necessarily don't mistake the two I
think you're crazy I think you're naive
oh where women obey their man women have
children women have big families women
are exceptionally happy to do so yes
before before some Western Bill comes in
here and runs their mouth the Islamic
women are happier than any you're gonna
see in the club tonight yeah very true
okay I would buy that Society is
functioning their population is growing
because in most Western countries the
population is declining yep is talking
about it today I'm sorry we'll have one
kid it doesn't work doesn't work right
do you two people need to have 3.1 kids
because people die right people die
prematurely blah blah we do have too
many people on the Earth
I don't know why we're complaining and I
need somebody to explain it to me in
more detail why we're complaining about
the population of the West going down we
have 8 billion people on this [ __ ]
planet all the climate control climate
crisis people do is cry if we just meet
Thanos I had a half hat you know had
half the people we might be okay there
would be less people eating less people
driving less people farting you know us
cows farting cows farting thank God that
would save it that would save us cow
farts patient problems Society is
functioning and that's that's what
Society is society is society starts at
the smallest possible group you have
families and families make a street and
that street makes a village and that
Village makes a town that town makes a
city and that City makes a country so if
it's broken at the very fundamental
level with family levels broken that has
broken the whole way up yep yep and
that's what's happened in the west and
the first world Islamic countries have
none of those problems so if you're
going to talk about a belief system that
fixes issues
you need to go to Islam
everything but I just have absolutely
even though I wouldn't identify as
Muslim I have I have absolute respect
for the ideology respect for the
mentality respect for the warrior aspect
of it I respect they don't blink they
don't play you can't solve their [ __ ]
but you can insult the church all day
you can make fun Show on Netflix about
God gay Jesus that's a joke right and
what do the Christians do nothing
Christians Christianity is a dead
religion if you're a Christian and I'm
saying this is a Christian myself
Christianity is a dead religion which is
confined to to the history
stopped watching Netflix and then all of
a sudden Netflix started to suffer
seriously financially their
subscriptions were down and all of a
sudden now they're not woke anymore and
they're done with all that [ __ ] and
they're putting out regular programming
again so we did do something we turn
away we turn the other cheek we let it
be and we pure flicks came out of it
your own Pope Pope goes up there and
talks lgbtq [ __ ] that's crazy it is over
you don't stand for anything you don't
believe in anything you have no
boundaries you're walked on you're
mocked the whole thing is a joke being a
Christian now is nothing more than
advertising you're a loser it's a losing
religion okay I'll tell you this lost to
his life if he not one person not one
comment and we're talking thousands that
we've gotten on these Islam videos of
the negative have been negative and [ __ ]
on Christianity not one so I need all
you people to go to Tate and fix his
head because he's not nice he's not
being nice
he's not being a pumpkin at all all the
Muslims have been pumpkins every one of
them more so than sneako snico forgot
about us what would you give one to ten
on this you know I love Tate I'm very
disappointed in how he finds the need
and I know that's the fighter in him
that he can't just win he can't just be
happy without you know beating the [ __ ]
out of somebody else first it's it's an
actual metaphor for his life you don't
have to [ __ ] on someone else in order to
talk about how great it is to be Muslim
you don't have to [ __ ] on Christians it
doesn't have to be that way and I think
you need to talk to more Muslims who are
really truly understanding of how
closely related these religions are
which we're learning and I'm Amazed by
it and I'm I'm moved by it frankly it's
interesting that he shits on it too back
then and then he called himself a
Christian and he goes to church it's
very it's very strange yeah in the same
kind conversation in the same video he's
like I give I'm an orthodox Catholic and
I give twenty thousand dollars a month
to the church and [ __ ] those people
they're my [ __ ] idiots like what what
are you doing what's the matter with you
straighten them out somebody's straight
you might be will straighten them out
let's go to Romania talk to him you go
I'm tired I got things to do I'll go
I'll FaceTime I'll be like hey my mom
thinks you're uh videos a year old I'd
like to see him update that conversation
and I hope it's more enlightened than
that was yikes make sure you hit the
[ __ ] subscribe button and if you want
to learn how to make money online and go
viral on social media click the Discord
Link in my description I have some free
sauce to give you guys and yeah you can
learn to make money online in as little
as 30 days so see ya
and
[Music]